we're really excited about the class of
2017 over fifty percent are female
and they're from countries all over the
world Costa Rica India Romania we're
just very excited about the diversity
and the quality of the students that are
coming in how science has done worldwide
is changing it's more interdisciplinary
it's more collaborative it's more
communicative the boundaries between
departments are certainly as low as they
have ever been the ability to
collaborate across universities and
countries because of communication
technology is is the best it's ever been
and our students here at the Mellon
College of Science really benefit from
all of that we have a new core education
that focuses on educating the whole
student science is more
interdisciplinary we stress
communication skills we stress teamwork
ninety percent of the undergraduates in
chemistry biology and physics have
research experience in an actual lab
with faculty they present their work at
conferences they present posters their
names are actually as they're named as
authors on publications and this is an
experience that most undergraduates
don't have and it really taps into the
culture of Carnegie Mellon we are a
highly collaborative institution our
walls between departments and
disciplines are very low and this new
core education actually allows us to
educate students across boundaries very
easily
our advisors really are the gold
standard for the university and their
approach is like none other probably in
the country they get to know the
students individually they know the
university well enough to encourage the
students to become involved in different
opportunities that really round out
their person and their experience at
Carnegie Mellon today's students want to
give back to the world
so these additional things beyond a core
education and science really are
attractive to the modern-day student